hi there and welcome to biographics I'm
your interim host Carl small and today
we're talking about Marilyn Monroe the
ultimate Hollywood sex symbol by Radu
Alexander
Fame is like caviar it's good to have
caviar but not when you have it for
every meal those were the words of Molly
Monroe and indeed Thane proves to be a
double-edged sword for the sultry
platinum blonde actress outwardly she
projected the image of a silly
self-assured sexy Airhead who had all
the men bowing at her feet it was an
archetype that played well in Hollywood
and had done for many years prior to
Monroe but after Monroe she made it her
own even now over half a century later
the notion of the blonde bombshell makes
many people instantly think of Marilyn
Monroe perhaps in the iconic white dress
getting swept up by Augusta passing wind
behind closed doors however everything
was not okay first Marlene endured an
unhappy childhood where she was moved
around from place to place and
eventually pressured into a marriage she
didn't really want just to avoid the
orphanage deep-seated feelings of
Abandonment and not being wanted haunted
her throughout her life and had an
adverse effects on her relationships and
her career eventually her demons got the
best of her and Marilyn ended her life
at the tender age at 36 when she was
still the Apex of her career her time in
Hollywood then was surprisingly breach
but a legacy is one of Cinema legendary
stars is Everlasting
as the pub quiz aficionados amongst you
will know Molly Monroe was born Norma
Jean Mortensen on June 1st 1926 in Los
Angeles California although she was soon
baptized as Norma Jean Baker after a
Mother Gladys Pearl Baker when Norma
Jean was born Gladys was struggling both
mentally and financially and was in no
position to be a mother her first
marriage which resulting two children
proved abusive and ended when she was
only 19 years old her ex-husband then
kidnapped their children and took them
to his native Kentucky where he started
a new life for himself Gladys spent what
little money she had to track down her
kids but ultimately let them go since
they had a better life in Kentucky than
she could provide back for them back in
Los Angeles in 1924 Gladys married again
well this relationship only lasted for a
few months before the couple separated
after that Gladys had a string of lovers
and soon became pregnant with Norma Jean
who we'll just call Marilyn from now on
to avoid confusion nobody was really
sure who Madeline's father was nobody
other than got this herself who insisted
that the father was a man named Charles
Stanley Gifford a sales manager at
Consolidated Studios where Gladys worked
as a film cutter however she had no way
of proving this at the time it was just
a gut instinct and that wasn't good
enough for Gifford who knew that and
Gladys said being with other men and
wanted nothing to do with raising the
child modern technology however has
Vindicated Gladys Baker's instincts as a
recent DNA test concluded like Gifford
was indeed Marilyn Monroe's father as
far as we know Marilyn never met her
father she tried once but only ran to
his wife unsurprisingly this had a
profound impact on Monroe's development
she was often attracted to older men
later in life and even called him dad or
daddy truly a Trailblazer normally a
baby's arrive was called to a
celebration but not in this case Gladys
Baker had a history of depression and
mood swings as did her mother Della and
those were greatly exacerbated by
Marilyn's birth it's likely that Glady
suffered from postpartum depression but
this was at a time when few people
understood the condition and even fewer
cared her mental state was undoubtedly
made even worse with a stigma and shame
that Society pursued upon single on
webmothers at the time at the very least
Gladys had the state of mind to
understand that motherhood was just too
much for her right then and she agreed
to give up Marilyn just two weeks after
she was born we'll agreed my might be
too strong a word her choice was hurried
along after glad he's trying to stab a
friend of hers after accusing her of
poisoning her child so on June 13th and
babe Marilyn ended up in the home of
Wayne and Ida belender who lived in
Hawthorne California across the street
from Marion's grandmother Della Baker
unfortunately living close to grandma
wasn't always Christ not to be one day
during a visit Ida Belinda walked in on
Della Baker trying to smother Marilyn in
her crib the police were called and from
then on Dallas mental state still
deteriorated until she died about a year
later Melanie spent the first seven
years of her life with the Belinda it's
just how bad it was as well that's a
matter of opinion later in life Marilyn
Monroe certainly taught up her rough
childhood to emphasize her rights to
Rich's story uh saying that it was
strict and religious and bordering on
zealotry but one of the Belinda's
daughters disputed many of her claims so
who knows who's really telling the truth
here
very full I'm really going to spill it
on my laptop or the mic as funny as that
would be view the audience at home in
1993 Gladys got a life back on track and
got Marilyn back under Roosevelt's New
Deal she had managed to obtain a loan
for a down payment on a house near
Hollywood Bowl and while renting a
bedroom to the Atkinson Family George
and Maude and their young daughter Nelly
like Gladys Baker the Atkinsons were on
the periphery of Hollywood with both
husband and wife occasionally Landing
bit Parts in movies they're also a lot
loose of an either blender they like to
smoke drink dance and play cards all the
fun stuff that sends you straight to
hell but Marilyn still liked and enjoyed
hearing about all the stories in
Hollywood and for the first time she
began wondering what such a life would
be like for her
the new living Arrangement seems to work
out pretty well by Dark Storm Sue cloud
of the sunshine and rainbows just a few
months after moving into the new house
Gladys received some Dreadful news
Jackie her boy from her first marriage
had died of tuberculosis a short while
later she also found out that her
grandmother who commits suicide after
allegedly going Matt even at the best of
times guys Baker's mental state was
precarious but two tragedies in a row
sent it on a downward spiral she lashed
out at Marlene telling her she should
have died instead of jacket then one day
she suffered a full-on psychotic break
banishing her knife to protect herself
for Imaginary attackers at that point
Gladys Baker was undoubtedly a danger to
both herself and everybody around her so
the police were called and they sent her
for a psychiatric evaluation class was
diagnosed as a paranoid schizophrenic
and committed to a mental hospital the
next years of Marilyn's life for a bit
uncertain and she drifted between
different homes and orphanages in 1935
Marilyn thought she had found a new home
with Grace McKee her mother's dearest
friend and at the same woman that Gladys
wants tried to stab after accusing her
of poisoning Marilyn after Gladys was
committed Grace became Marilyn's legal
guardian but now that she had her she
decided all the things she wanted more
grace McKee had just gotten married for
the fourth time to a man who already had
three kids a middle-aged woman she was
desperate to hang on to his husband so
when he said that three kids were enough
and that Marilyn had to go she relented
and sent her back to the orphanage and
Marlene am I like rough I only spent
about a year and a half in the Los
Angeles orphans home she described it as
one of the darkest periods of her life
but just like her using the blenders
orphanage officials of accuser of making
up most of the horrible things she
described possibly to give herself more
of a tragic and compelling backstory
again since nobody's pants caught on
fire we're not really sure who was
telling the truth in this situation
after leaving the orphanage Marlene was
passed around like a beach volleyball
for she stayed with Grace McKee and her
family again and she was sent to leave
with her elderly Aunt Anna lower when
the ant became too sickly took after her
like the girl returned to Grace for a
bit then the whole family would planned
to move to Virginia and Marilyn wasn't
invited along for the trip faced the
possibility of returning to the
orphanage maling look for an alternative
any alternative and she found that in
the boy next door James Doherty Marilyn
James were already Sweeting each other
and she was just about to turn 16. they
thought why not get married that never
goes wrong so they did and they got
hitched in 1942 soon after Marilyn came
of legal age with Grace's full support
that way McKee could pack up and move to
Virginia with a clear conscience that
same year Marilyn dropped out of high
school and became a housewife while
docerty worked at the Lockheed Factory
in Van nuz much like every other new
arrangement in Monroe's life this one
was short-lived in 1943 Doherty joined
the Merchant Navy so the couple
relocated to Catalina Island a year
later he got shipped to the Pacific so
Marilyn went to the Van Nuys again and
moved him with in-laws and then soon
after they've actually found her first
job with a company called radio plane
which manufactured drones that were used
for Gunnery targets and who could have
seen it would be here in of all places
that Marilyn Monroe would emerge as a
star
[Music]
one day in late 1944 a man walked into
the radio plane officers his name was
David Conover and he was a photographer
with yank magazine a military
publication during World War II he was
looking to do a morale boosting feature
on women in the workplace to show The
Lads were deployed what they were
fighting for several women posed for
Conover but Marilyn immediately caught
his eye he saw something in her and
concluded that she would make a great
Pinot model and he was right Conover
used Marlin several more times and
spread the word about this new great
girl he discovered and she came hit
overnight with dozens of fellow shoots
in her first year as a model alone this
caused shall we say tensions with her
husband who was not happy about his
wife's new career Dr T was old school he
wrote Marilyn Alesso and he made it
clear that once he was back he expects
her to settle down give up a modeling
career and start a family but that
didn't sit well with Marilyn she wasn't
the scared innocent girl needs to be
saved as she was when they got married
now Marilyn can look after herself and
she was not about to give up a
flourishing career just because somebody
else told it to in 1946 Jim Doherty came
back home his feelings had not changed
at all so Marilyn was forced to make a
decision her marriage or a career I
think we all know that she chose the
latter divorcing dockete that same year
her personal life might have taken a hit
but professional life was just one
success after another in February 1946
for example Marilyn made the inspired
decision to change her look like so she
straight into her curls dyed her hair
blonde and added a signature beauty mark
she want me to resemble her Idol Eugene
Harlow Hollywood's original blonde
bombshell on someone who incidentally
we've already covered here at
biographics link
somewhere on screen with our previous
more aerodynamic Host this new look made
Marilyn even more popular and inevitably
came the transition to movies everyone
kept telling her she was pretty enough
to be in the pictures I saw a modeling
agent and like Snavely arrange a screen
testing Marilyn and Ben Lyon a recruiter
for 20th Century Fox Studio bigwig
Daryl's the Nook was exactly bowed over
by a performance but it was sufficiently
impressed he wants to keep her away from
the competition so he put the boarding
Style on a payroll 75 a week for six
months with the option for the studio to
renew and double the salary all that was
missing was a name because Norma Jean
Baker didn't exactly scream Glitz and
glamor so the actual sound used the
first name Marilyn after Broadway star
Marilyn Miller and her mother's maiden
name Monroe and also the transformation
from Norma Jean Mortensen to Marilyn
Monroe was complete so now she had the
name and she had the lock but it was
still a while before she had the star
power as we said 20th Century Fox didn't
immediately see box office gold in her
so she spent her first six months on
contract without actually appearing in
any movies but she still got paid that's
the important thing always get paid she
used that tie to take acting singing
dancing lessons with the occasional
appearance of press layouts where all
those expect of it was to smile and look
pretty something she'd been doing for
years finally in February 1947 the 21
year old Monroe landed her first acting
gig a bit part in the movie dangerous
years when she played a waitress a few
more roles followed but they're all
small time and some even uncredited and
admittedly uncredited appearance is the
way a lot of actors cut their teeth like
fun fact Jennifer Aniston's like first
role in a feature film was in the
infamous McDonald's dance scene in mac
and Men right blinking you'd miss it we
can find on YouTube it's probably in the
comments links because why would you not
cry like that she's also in Leprechaun
one and two right oh no it was
Leprechaun one yeah she left corn one
and watch that movie because it is just
an absolute Showcase of style now
clearly she had not impressed anyone
without acting chop so when a second
contract expired Fox did not renew it
she's done a new deal with Colombia in
1948 but this went even worse although
Marilyn landed her first ever leading
role in later the chorus the movie was a
bomb and the studio dropped her like a
hot potato soon after release I wonder
if they came till we get that one like
yeah we signed Marilyn Monroe right now
we're good so Marilyn returns a modeling
to pay the bills this was when she also
posed noon for the pinup photographer
Tom Kelly under the name Nona Monroe it
wasn't something she was proud of but
she needed to make a car payment and
Kelly promised that nobody would
recognize it was her the last part
didn't exactly work out since Hugh
Hefner infamously bought the photographs
four years later when Marilyn Monroe was
a star and he used them for the first
issue of his new magazine Playboy it
sounds like Marilyn Monroe might not be
made for the movies after all however
she had been told that you could never
predict when you'll get your big break
in Hollywood and but then when it
happens you'll know and for Monroe it
happened on New Year's Eve 1949 the
party producer Sam Spiegel where she
shook the hand of Johnny Hyde
[Music]
thank you
at first glance Johnny Hardy was nothing
to look at it was a short balding
middle-aged man with a sickly appearance
and a bad ticker but as the vice
president of the William Morris Talent
Agency he was also one of the most
powerful men in the room and the moment
he laid eyes on Marilyn he was smitten
his proposition to her was exactly what
you'd expect become his mistress and
he'll make her a star never change
Hollywood never change that's sarcastic
by the way I'm just the delivery was
just very drying although by the end of
their year-long relationship he's the
power Dynamic had shifted completely and
it was Hyde who was working non-stop to
please Monroe terrified that she might
leave him while she constantly buffed
his marriage proposals get it girl
admittedly on a professional level Holly
did deliver on his promises he knew that
maolin wanted more than anything else to
be seen as a serious actress not just a
sexy Airhead so he got her wrong in John
Houston's film Noir the asphalt John
gone in 1950. along Monroe only had a
few minutes of screen time it was the
first time she received praise for her
acting that same year she had another
minor on the greatest movies of all time
the seminal Drama All About Eve which is
still tide of Titanic for record for
most Oscar nominations with 14. again
another one out there for you uh pub
quiz aficionados these two hits were
followed by several Mediocre Films that
only became noteworthy because they
included a young Malin rep otherwise
they would have been doomed to
irrelevancy as soon as they were
released but Hyde wanted any roles he
could for monrem hoping that actually
got featured enough one of the big
studios would eventually notice and
offer a contract ultimately he got his
wish and in December 1950 20th Century
Fox offered Monroe a new seven-year
contract with his job done Hyde had a
heart attack and tagged a few days later
tickled me
it's just like his only goal was like
yeah it's like just I'm imagining all
his death that are like yes I'm okay
with this Monroe's famous now
oh just like Vegeta doing the Final
Flash so I've never embraced you as
I've never acknowledged you as an
actress Marvel Angel
stricken with grief Marlin blamed
herself for his heart attack I I can see
why an older man with a bad heart
getting to be with Marilyn Monroe at 20
years old would cause an old man's heart
to give out but blaming herself and
feeling a lot of grief for it Malin
attempted to commit suicide a few days
after the funeral her acting coach fan a
passed out in bed with several sleeping
pills still dissolving in her mouth this
likely being her first attempt at
killing herself Marilyn didn't take
enough pills to get the job done and her
coach's able to remove the pills from
her mouth and shake her awake Marlene
would later completely dismiss the event
as an accident but she had already begun
abusing the pills to cope with the
disappointments in her life a habit that
only got worse as the years went on
After High's death Marilyn went on a
much publicized string of short-lived
high-profile affairs with including the
director Ella Kazan director Peter
Lawford who would later introduce her to
the Kennedys this culminated in her
second marriage this time to New York
Yankees star player Joe DiMaggio which
only lasted nine months on a
professional level morons created flop
where it had stagnated during the early
1950s she made a bunch of moderately
successful movies for Fox Studios where
she was once again relegated to playing
the sexy Don blonde there were some
exceptions such as the Noir Clash by
Knight and the Thriller don't bother to
knock but Monroe was still looking for
that breakout role to launch a career
into the stratosphere
1953 was the year that made Monroe's
career she started the Year by appearing
in the film Noir Niagara or Niagara I'm
not sure how you like Americans
pronounce it I like pronouncing it
Niagara well Niagara is I've also heard
so just either one of those right
let me know in the comments I suppose
well she played a thin fatal who was
still heavy on the sex appeal but less
so on the ditziness that defined most of
her roles later that year she starred in
the movie adaptation of the comedy
Musical that was seemingly written for
her gentleman Prefer Blondes where she
showcased their scene in dancing skills
in her memorable rendition of Diamonds
Are a Girl's Best Friend Monroe finished
off the Year by staying in the comedy
movie how to Marry a Millionaire
alongside Lauren Bacall and Betty gravon
all three movies were big hits and
cemented Monroe's status one of
Hollywood's greatest Rising Stars her
second stint at Fox was cut off by the
Billy Wilder comedy The Seven Year Itch
which featured arguably one of the most
iconic images of the 20th century when
Monroe's white cocktail dress gets blown
upwards by the wind from a subway train
passing underneath I'm hoping we can
show this because it is a still for a
movie but whenever it comes to these
iconic images there's always someone out
there who bought the rights to it and
charges money for putting it in there so
if we did
yeah
at this point Molly Monroe had become
Undisputed Hollywood royalty but she was
still bothered by the blonde Airhead
archetype she kept portraying she but
had several times with Fox exactly over
her pass as they felt any other roles
would be unsuited to her eventually she
said screw that and move to New York
where she opened her own production
company Marilyn Monroe Productions 20th
Century Fox mother begged to differ and
his sister that Monroe was still under
contract with them this launched a
year-long legal battle between the two
sides a time during which some ridiculed
Monroe for torpy doing her own career
While others applauded her for taking on
the big studios to support actors rights
eventually the two sides reached an
agreement that was very favorable to
monreal and with her receiving not only
a big pay increase but also the ability
to choose her own projects and directors
he was a landmark moment a single the
beginning of the end for the studio
system Monroe's movie under a new deal
was the drama or start where she
downplayed her sex appeal and spoke with
an Ozark accent both the movie and
acting were all well received proving to
the world that Marilyn Monroe was not
just a one-trick pony the next film
however The Prince and the show girl was
wasn't quite as successful marked by
conflict between the movie's two leads
Monroe and Lawrence Olivier in fact by
that point Monroe had firmly established
having a reputation as let's put it
diplomatically difficult to work with
she was someone always showed up late
often have got their lines and demanded
countless retakes until she felt that
everything was right this attitude
caused the most problems on the set of
one of her final and undoubtedly one of
her best Billy Wilder's comedy Some Like
It Hot by the end of Productions the
director was not speaking to Monroe
anymore and he later made multiple
disparaging comments about her in the
Press Wilder put it bluntly to the Press
stating that while Marilyn was good she
probably wasn't worth all the trouble
capping It Off by stating I'm too old
and too rich to ever go through
something like that again and if
anyone's curious about the exact details
of how this went down it's reported that
Marilyn took about 30 to 50 tanks to say
there was like goodnight Sugar
because she couldn't remember the exact
intonation of how to say it and like
this understandably caused the director
to be incredibly frustrated to the point
where the lines were written on a piece
of paper in front of her and she's still
got it wrong I actually wrote about that
for top tens a few years ago if the
editor couldn't remember or keeps his
bit in maybe link that below
hello Marlene's career headaches ups and
downs her personal life seems to be a
string of disappointments heartbreaks
and failure she married playwright
Arthur Miller in 1956 and all this was
her longest marriage he still ended in
divorce in 1961. afterwards it is
presumed that she had an Infamous affair
with President Kennedy and his brother
Bobby Kennedy although it has never been
definitively proven in fact many people
believe a popular conspiracy theory that
says the Kennedys was somehow involved
in Maryland's death which include her
second husband Joe DiMaggio behind
closed doors Marilyn was also dealing
with a host of health problems she
suffered two miscarriages and one
ecoptic pregnancy in her life and also
had to deal with very painful God sounds
her physical and emotional pain made her
turn to drugs and by the end of her life
she became addicted to barbiturates
while filming her final movie
Something's Got to Give Monroe had to
take an extended sick leave which
prompters Fox to fire her and seek
replacement however by now you think the
studio would have learned that they
always got the short end of the stick
when they went up against the force of
nature that was Marilyn Monroe her
co-star Dean Martin refused to work with
anybody else eventually the studio
rehired her with a payroll eyes not for
this movie but also for a next one
Monroe stood to earn around a million
dollars for two movies a giant sum in
those days the studio would never have
to pay out though because on the evening
of August 5th 1962 manly Monroe died in
her home from our obituary overdose the
36 year old actor's death officially
ruled a probable suicide although as we
mentioned there are quite a few
conspiracy theories that surround her
untimely demise the end result was that
Marilyn Monroe's life her career and yes
even her tragic death combined to form
one of the most popular and enduring
figures in Hollywood history so cheers
to everyone for tuning in to this
episode of biographics as mentioned at
the start I'm your interim host Carl
Smallwood I use arrived top tens a few
years ago and asked me to step in and
due to my experience hosting my own
channel vaccine with Carl Smallwood
which you can no doubt find linked below
like leave a like comment subscribe all
that good stuff and remember as always
to have the day you deserve
Hello Kitty mug it was my sisters and I
stole it because I'm a good Big Brother